Für mich gab es irgendwann
einen Moment, in dem ich wusste,
dass ein Kind
zu meinem Leben gehören soll.
Ich wusste schon immer,
dass ich gerne Kinder haben
und auch eine solche Familie
aufbauen möchte.
Sowohl Larissa als auch ich
arbeiten gern.
Budget versus Impact, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Wenn du z.B. 200 ...
Wir sind wieder
auf den Uetliberg unterwegs.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie oft ich das noch mache.
(Ärztin) Das kommt manchmal vor.
Man muss es nochmals untersuchen.
Ich kann mir die Geburt
noch nicht vorstellen.
Hier steht eine Badewanne.
Das habe ich mir gewünscht, aber
ich kann mir noch nicht vorstellen,
dass ich in dieser Badewanne sitze
und ein Kind gebäre.
* Piepsen
eines medizinischen Geräts *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In der Stadt Zürich kommen pro Jahr
5'000 Kinder auf die Welt.
Fast die Hälfte davon im Triemli,
dem Stadtspital Zürich.
In Sichtweite zum Spital
wohnen hier zuoberst Larissa Gerhard
und Fabian Künzli.
Das Paar erwartet sein erstes Kind,
Larissa
ist im sechsten Monat schwanger.
In ihrer Wohnung schaffen sie Platz
für den neuen Lebensabschnitt.
Gefällt es dir so?
- Nein.
(Lachend) Irgendetwas
ist ganz und gar nicht in Ordnung.
Wollen wir versuchen,
es bis zur Kante zu schieben?
Und wenn wir ihn
hier hinstellen würden?- Wie?
So?
Ist es nicht okay?
Wenn es am Boden steht,
wahrscheinlich schon.
Ich finde ... Nein.
- War es vorhin besser?
Ja.
Wenn dies das Fenster ist,
das wir öfter öffnen ...
Nein, dort kommt die Lampe hin.
Die kann man auch
hier hinten platzieren.- Nein.
Die Geburt des ersten Kindes
verändert das Leben als Paar -
auch wenn man sich gut kennt.
So geht sie unter.
Nein.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja?- Dort drüben
sieht es wunderschön aus.
Ja.
* Lachen *
Ja, mir gefällt es.
Wir kennen uns
schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Wir kennen uns,
seit wir zwölf waren.
Wir gingen zusammen zur Schule
und waren befreundet.
Wir wuchsen im selben Dorf auf.
- Genau.
Wir können nicht mal
mehr wirklich sagen,
an welchem Tag wir ein Paar wurden.
Es geschah wahrscheinlich
nicht von heute auf morgen.
Unsere Beziehung wuchs von einer
wichtigen, starken Freundschaft
zu einer Liebesbeziehung.
Daher ist es für mich
immer total schwierig ...
Ich weiss gar nicht, wie viele Jahre
wir schon zusammen sind,
weil die Beziehung
schon viel länger bestehen könnte
und Fabian schon viel länger
Teil meines Lebens ist.
Wir sind auf dem Weg ...
Wir haben heute
etwas Besonderes vor.
Erzähl. Wohin gehen wir?
Wir gehen heute zu meinen Eltern.
- Schaut.
Wir haben zwei Ballone vorbereitet.
Wir wollen meinen Eltern das
Geschlecht unseres Babys verraten
bzw. sie müssen es anhand der
zerplatzten Ballone herausfinden.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Und los!
Ah!
* Lachen *
Das Triemli liegt
am Fusse des Uetlibergs.
Das Spital für den Grossraum Zürich
vereint alle wichtigen medizi-
nischen Disziplinen unter einem Dach.
In der Frauenklinik kommen jeden Tag
sechs bis sieben Kinder auf die Welt.
Auf der Wochenbettstation ist heute
Hebamme Caroline Suter unterwegs.
Mein Name ist Suter. Ich bin heute
die für Sie zuständige Hebamme.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Okay.
Noch etwas müde?
- Ja.
Rund um die Uhr kommen
in der Frauenklinik Kinder zur Welt.
Entsprechend gross
ist das Hebammenteam.
Caroline Suter ist eine von 45.
Seit zwei Jahren
ist Caroline Suter im Triemli tätig
und sie hat schon 200 Babys
auf die Welt begleitet.
Wollen wir dich schnell wiegen?
Dann ist das schon erledigt.
* Schreien *
Na?
Das mögen sie meistens.
Eine kleine Kopfmassage.
* Das Baby macht wohlige Laute. *
Wer schwanger ist,
macht sich im Voraus Gedanken,
wo das Kind zur Welt kommen soll.
Caroline Suter
wird in ein paar Monaten
auch die Hebamme
von Larissa und Fabian sein.
Die Ärmchen nach unten.
* Das Baby weint. *
Ja, ja, ich habe es verstanden,
Spitzbub.
So.
Wir vertrauen dem Triemli-Spital
in unserer Nähe.
Sie haben gewiss viel Erfahrung.
Daher haben wir uns
dafür entschieden.
Mir ist es sehr wichtig,
sie in Sicherheit zu wissen,
weil es unser erstes Kind ist
und wir nicht wissen,
was auf uns zukommt.
Wieso soll ich
noch grossartig weitersuchen,
wenn das Triemli
vor unserer Haustür liegt?
Im medizinischen Notfall
möchte man sich auf Spezialistinnen
verlassen können.
Im Stadtspital Zürich hat es auch
eine Neonatologie und Kinderklinik.
Ärztinnen aller Abteilungen
tauschen sich zweimal pro Tag
über die Patientinnen aus.
Am Tisch sitzt auch Natalia Conde -
sie ist leitende Frauenärztin.
Nach dem Morgenrapport macht sie sich
auf den Weg in den Operationssaal.
Hast du sie vorhin noch gesehen?
- Ja.
Gynäkologie ist auch
ein chirurgisches Fach.
Natalia Conde bereitet sich
auf einen Routineeingriff vor.
Trotz des hochspezialisierten Umfelds
geht manchmal vergessen,
dass bei jedem operativen Eingriff
und bei jeder Geburt
auch etwas schiefgehen könnte.
* Rhythmisches Piepsen *
Tipptopp.
Nimmst du das Grössere?
- Ja.
Einer jungen Patientin
entfernt die leitende Ärztin
ein gutartiges Geschwür
in der Gebärmutter.
* Piepsen des Herzmonitors *
Letztlich lief es sehr gut.
Ich sah das Myom gut
und konnte es wegschneiden.
Ich machte nicht mehr, da sie
noch jung ist und Kinder möchte.
Ich wollte nicht zu viel
gesunde Schleimhaut entfernen.
Ansonsten wird es schwierig,
schwanger zu werden.
Der Kinderwunsch
kam auch bei Fabian auf.
Für mich gab es irgendwann
einen Moment, in dem ich wusste,
dass ein Kind
zu meinem Leben gehören soll.
Ich möchte nicht
mit 80 sterben und ...
... kein Kind haben.
Ich bin ein totaler Familienmensch.
Ich wuchs mit drei Geschwistern auf.
Wir sind eine sechsköpfige Familie.
Die Familie ist für mich alles.
Sie ist für mich total wichtig.
Ich wusste schon immer,
dass ich gerne Kinder haben
und auch eine solche Familie
aufbauen möchte.
Fabian und Larissa
sind beide berufstätig.
Schon vor der Geburt
suchen sie einen Krippenplatz.
Das ist in Zürich üblich,
weil Plätze für Babys rar sind.
Hallo, Fabian, ich bin Caroline.
Wir haben telefoniert. Komm rein.
Im Erdgeschoss
haben wir eine Gruppe.
Dies ist das Badezimmer der Gruppe.
- Ja.
Das ist die Gruppe Füchse.
Fabian ist selbstständiger Berater.
Er und Larissa wollen
hochprozentig in ihren Job zurück
und sich die Familienarbeit
zur Hälfte teilen.
Sie suchen einen Krippenplatz
für zwei Wochentage.
Dies ist die Gruppe Uhu.
Sowohl Larissa als auch ich
arbeiten gern.
Wir sind auch relativ ambitioniert.
Heutzutage sollte man sich
als Mensch nicht komplett aufgeben,
"nur" weil ein Kind oder sogar zwei
ins eigene Leben treten.
Der Papi-Tag ist eingeplant.
Mir ist es extrem wichtig,
dass der Vater
meines oder meiner Kinder
eine Vaterrolle einnimmt.
Ich habe den Papi-Tag, den wir
hatten, in extrem guter Erinnerung.
Mein Papa war sehr oft präsent.
Das finde ich extrem wichtig.
Das ist genauso wichtig
wie meine Rolle als Mama.
Diese wird anfangs gewiss
etwas intensiver sein,
aber danach ist es mir sehr wichtig,
dass wir gemeinsam
eine Familie sind.
Larissa arbeitet
im urbanen Kreis 5 in Zürich.
Hast du etwas von der Stadt gesehen?
Die 31-Jährige ist Vollzeit
im Marketing eines
internationalen Unternehmens tätig,
das gegen Food Waste kämpft.
Larissa ist mittlerweile
im siebten Monat schwanger.
Eben erst wurde sie noch befördert.
Als die Beförderung
diskutiert wurde,
wussten wir natürlich,
dass Larissa schwanger ist.
Und ...
Sie ist seit Beginn extrem engagiert
und für uns war es
eine logische Entscheidung,
Larissa zu befördern,
als die neue Struktur des Teams
geplant wurde.
Und ... ähm ...
Wir wussten natürlich, dass sie
ein paar Monate weg sein wird,
und wir wissen auch nicht genau,
wann sie zurückkommt,
aber das Privatleben
ist ein Teil des Lebens.
Wir sollten uns
von der Vorstellung lösen,
dass wir im Job nur Leistung bringen
und immer präsent sein müssen.
Ein Baby zu kriegen,
ist etwas Wichtiges,
und wir müssen das
in unseren Alltag integrieren.
Das gilt auch
für uns als Arbeitgeber.
In der neuen Rolle
als Marketingmanagerin
führt Larissa zwei Mitarbeiterinnen.
Führungsverantwortung will sie
auch nach der Babypause übernehmen.
Wir haben keinen Gewichtsheber.
Ich dachte an den Schwingerkönig.
Ja.
Ich arbeite extrem flexibel.
Mein Laptop ist mein Arbeitsgerät,
ansonsten brauche ich nichts.
D.h., ich kann immer
und überall arbeiten.
Ich möchte sehr hochprozentig
in meinen Job zurückkehren.
Ich mag meinen Job sehr
und freue mich, ins Team und
zu meinen Projekten zurückzukehren.
Ich möchte meine neue Position
wieder wahrnehmen
und mein Team weiter aufbauen.
Wie lange ich weg sein werde,
weiss ich noch nicht.
Ich habe offiziell 18 Wochen
bezahlten Mutterschaftsurlaub.
Während dieser Zeit werde ich
auf jeden Fall weg sein.
Man hat immer eine Idealvorstellung,
aber ob alles nach Plan läuft,
weiss man nicht.
Ob es länger dauern wird,
weil ich noch Ferien dranhänge,
sei dahingestellt.
Manchmal hat Larissa noch Mühe,
sich vorzustellen,
wie das Leben mit Kind sein wird.
Ich bin gespannt, wie unser Leben
als junge Familie wird
und wie wir das
mit der Kinderbetreuung
und unseren Jobs meistern werden.
Wir müssen alles
unter einen Hut bringen.
* Larissa atmet schwer. *
Dies ist unser wöchentliches,
gemeinsames Ausdauertraining.
Früher joggten wir, nun gehen wir,
aber das klappt gut.
(Schwer atmend) Ich weiss nicht,
wie oft ich das noch machen werde.
Es wird jedes Mal
etwas anstrengender.
Morgen beginnt
die 29. Schwangerschaftswoche
und mein Bauch wird immer dicker.
Obwohl ich wegen des Bauchs
etwas ausser Atem gerate,
ist es immer total schön,
frühmorgens ...
... den Uetliberg zu erklimmen.
Ich geniesse es total.
Das ist der perfekte Start
in den Tag - auch in den Ferien.
Es dauert noch zwei Monate
bis zum Geburtstermin.
Larissas langjährige Frauenärztin
hat sie ans Stadtspital überwiesen.
Beim letzten Ultraschall
schien am Herz des ungeborenen Kindes
etwas nicht in Ordnung.
Ich sah es sogar.
- Ja.
Ich bin nervös,
weil ich bei einer neuen Ärztin
und an einem neuen Ort bin.
Alle anderen Untersuchungen
fanden bei meiner langjährigen
Frauenärztin im Aargau statt.
Da wir nun in Zürich wohnen,
entschieden wir uns,
die Untersuchungen von jetzt an
im Triemli durchführen zu lassen,
um einen Bezug
zum Geburtsort zu kriegen.
Ich bin total gespannt.
Im Untersuchungszimmer
trifft das Paar heute zum ersten Mal
Gynäkologin Natalia Conde.
Sie will am Herz
den sog. Ausflusstrakt überprüfen.
Der Rücken ist zurzeit
auf der rechten Seite.
Wenn man diesen nicht sieht, ist ein
angeborener Herzfehler zu befürchten.
Hier ist die Blase des Babys.
Jetzt sehe ich das Herz sehr gut.
Hier sehen Sie die vier Kammern.
Das ist der sog. Vierkammerblick.
Nun sieht man, wie sich
die Klappen öffnen und schliessen.
Sie öffnen und schliessen sich.
Hier ist der rechte.
Sah Ihre Ärztin beide nicht?
Was sagte sie?
Nein, ich glaube,
sie sah auch einen nicht.
Aus den Kammern
kommen die sog. Ausflusstrakte.
Diese muss man sehen.
Und ... ähm ...
Man muss den Verlauf
darstellen können.- Okay.
Und ...
Und man sieht den linken nicht?
- Ja.
Also, es ist, wie es ist.
Ich sehe den linken Ausfluss
nicht eindeutig.
Von der Seite her sah ich ihn,
aber ich hätte gern
eine Zweitmeinung.
Die Ärztin empfiehlt
eine weitere Untersuchung
und Larissa macht
sich in der Schwangerschaft
zum ersten Mal Sorgen.
Ich mache mir schon Gedanken.
Mache ich etwas falsch?
Kann ich etwas tun ...
... damit es anders und besser wird?
Habe ich in den vergangenen
sieben Monaten etwas getan, das ...
... ich anders hätte machen können?
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass etwas nicht stimmt,
aber es löst
sehr viele Gedanken bei mir aus.
Dass gesunde Kinder
keine Selbstverständlichkeit sind,
geht heute gerne vergessen.
Hebammen sind für werdende Eltern
im Umgang mit Ängsten
eine wichtige Stütze.
Für Caroline Suter
beginnt kurz vor 23 Uhr
die Nachtschicht
auf der Gebärabteilung.
Im Stationszimmer verschaffen sich
die Hebammen einen Überblick,
was in den sieben Gebärsälen
los ist.
Caroline Suter schaut zuerst
zu einer Frau, die in Wehen liegt.
Das wär's.
- Gut, danke.
Wer hat Frau ...
- Eigentlich du, aber ...
Ich?
- ... das macht keinen Sinn.
Möchtest du?
- Noch nicht.
Sehr gut, super. Tief atmen.
* Eine Frau stöhnt. *
Diese Frau bekommt ihr erstes Baby
und hat seit 18 Uhr
regelmässige Wehen.
Der Muttermund ist noch geschlossen.
Nun versuchen wir,
sie etwas aufzupäppeln,
damit sie wieder nach Hause kann.
In dieser Phase wäre es besser,
wenn sie zu Hause wäre.
Die Frau fährt noch einmal
nach Hause - aber nicht für lange.
Eine halbe Stunde später
ruft sie erneut an.
In welchem Abstand kommen die Wehen?
Im Minutentakt?
Okay. Sind Sie schon zu Hause?
Wollen Sie nochmals vorbeikommen?
Oder wollen Sie ein Bad nehmen?
Dann erwarten wir Sie.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Kurze Zeit später
ist die werdende Mutter zurück -
und diesmal scheint es loszugehen.
* Laute Schmerzensschreie *
Dann müssen Sie sie
gar nicht mehr aufklären.
Im Zimmer nebenan ist heute Nacht
Dylon zur Welt gekommen.
Ja, die Mama
braucht lange zum Duschen.
Die Nachtschicht
verläuft sonst eher ruhig
und ein Gebärsaal
dient kurz als Pausenraum.
Guten Appetit.
(Corinne) Wir haben oft
keine Zeit zum Essen
oder wir essen im Stehen
schnell ein Sandwich oder so.
Ab und zu können wir uns
für eine halbe Stunde hinsetzen,
aber nie alle gemeinsam.
So wie heute ist es fast nie.
Schon geht's für die Hebamme weiter -
zu einer Frau, bei der die Geburt
mit Medikamenten eingeleitet wird.
Wie geht's?
- Es geht so.
Konnten Sie etwas schlafen?
- Ja.
Sie dürfen gleich weiterschlafen.
Ich gebe Ihnen die nächste Tablette.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Bevor die Nachtschicht endet,
fällt noch administrative Arbeit an.
Das sind in der Regel
die längsten Stunden.
Nach 7 Uhr kommt die Ablösung.
Nun steht ein neues Team
aus Hebammen und Ärztinnen
den Frauen in den Gebärsälen
zur Seite.
Guten Morgen.
Sie wird mit Yoga eingeleitet.
Es tut sich noch nichts.
Beim Termin von Erstgebärenden
wird eingeleitet bei ...
Ich gehe jetzt, ist das okay?
Ja. Schlaf gut.
- Einen guten Dienst.
Schlaf gut. Angel und der Rest
helfen dir.- Danke.
Tschüss.
Das Triemli bietet heute
noch einmal Larissa und Fabian auf.
Ich habe einen Ultraschalltermin
im Gebärsaal,
weil das Ultraschallgerät
dort viel besser geeignet ist,
um sich das Herz unserer Kleinen
genauer anzuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass alles okay ist.
Ich war schon etwas verunsichert,
als sie mich heute Morgen anriefen.
Eine Ultraschallspezialistin
untersucht erneut
das Herz des ungeborenen Kindes.
Wir sind zurück
von der Untersuchung.
Die Resultate
sind eigentlich nur positiv.
Mit dem Herz ist alles in Ordnung.
Der linke Ausflusstrakt
war endlich gut sichtbar
und es ist alles in Ordnung.
Alle unsere kleinen Sorgen
heute Morgen waren unbegründet.
Es ist alles okay.
Larissas Tatendrang ist zurück.
Neben ihrem Job
hat sie vor der Schwangerschaft
noch ein Unternehmen gegründet.
Sie backt Bananenbrot
in einer Industrieküche,
in die sie sich einmietet.
Das sind Bananen, die ...
... in Supermärkten
abends weggeworfen werden würden.
Ich rette diese Bananen,
backe daraus Bananenbrot
und schenke ihnen damit
ein zweites Leben.
Ich finde es furchtbar schade,
so schöne Bananen wegzuwerfen.
Um Bananenbrot zu backen,
benötigt man sowieso braune Bananen.
Nachhaltige Arbeit
ist Larissa wichtig.
Das gehört einfach zu mir
und ich würde es ungern aufgeben.
Ich glaube,
nur wenn ich in meinem Job
und in meinem Nebenprojekt
glücklich bin,
kann ich eine gute Mama sein.
Das befruchtet sich gegenseitig.
Das Geschäft soll weiter wachsen -
auch mit Kind.
Im Moment beliefert Larissa
die Kundschaft in Zürich noch selber.
Fabian wird bald übernehmen.
Zurzeit geht es noch.
Ich muss einfach
etwas breitbeiniger fahren
und bergauf
gerate ich ziemlich ausser Atem.
* Sie lacht. *
Momentan habe ich das Gefühl, dass
ich so weitermachen werde wie bisher
und dass wir später schauen werden,
was kommt.
Es kann sein,
dass ich plötzlich liegen muss,
nicht mehr in der Backstube stehen
und kein Brot mehr ausliefern kann.
Dann werden wir eine Lösung finden.
Dass das erste Kind
das Leben verändert,
wird den werdenden Eltern
immer mehr bewusst.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie es funktioniert,
wenn es um die klassischen
Erziehungsfragen geht.
Diesbezüglich habe ich wirklich
ein grosses Fragezeichen.
Das ist nicht negativ gemeint,
aber ich bin gespannt,
wie wir das angehen werden.
Ich glaube, es wird uns
als Individuen verändern,
aber als Paar ...
... definitiv auch.
Wir sind bereit für die Ferien.
Morgen geht es los,
wir fahren in die Toskana.
Die letzten Ferien allein.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Die Entwicklung des Babys haben sie
auf dem Smartphone verfolgt.
Jetzt ist das Baby
so gross wie ein Löwenbaby,
eine Portion Zuckerwatte ...
... oder eine Honigmelone.
* Larissa lacht. *
Er wuchs innert sechs Tagen 5,5 cm.
Er wuchs von einem Umfang von 94 cm
auf einen Umfang von 99,5 cm.
Das war letzten Freitag.
Ich bin gespannt, ob es in den
letzten fünf Wochen so weitergeht.
Larissa spürt die Extrakilos
und ihre Einstellung zum Job
hat sich auch verändert.
Ich mag nicht mehr am Stehpult
stehen und kann kaum sitzen.
Die Meetings verfolge ich
in halb liegender Position,
weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Ich kann mich
nicht mehr so gut konzentrieren,
wie ich es mir wünschen würde,
da mich die bevorstehende Geburt
und die Veränderung in meinem Leben
beschäftigen.
Es beschäftigt mich auch langsam,
dass ich zu wenig Zeit
für mich habe.
Deshalb will Larissa heute bei der
Ärztin ihr Arbeitspensum ansprechen.
Frau Gerhard, bitte.
- Guten Tag, Frau Conde.
Guten Tag. Bitte schön.
- Danke.
Klappt es noch gut mit der Arbeit?
Haben Sie Ihr Pensum reduziert?
Ich habe es auf 50 % reduziert.
Es ist auch ein emotionales Problem.
Ich kann mich nicht distanzieren.
Solange ich noch arbeite,
ist das sehr schwierig.
Seit ein paar Tagen
habe ich das Gefühl -
wie soll ich das ausdrücken -,
wenn das Baby früher kommt
und ich nur gearbeitet habe ...
Dann hatte ich irgendwie ...
- ... keine Zeit.
Ich habe keine Zeit für mich.
Daher wollte ich dieses Thema
auch noch ansprechen.
Okay.
Hier ist der Kopf und hier ...
... der Rücken, die Wirbelsäule.
So kann man es sich
besser vorstellen.
Das Kind entwickelt sich gut.
Die Gedanken an die Geburt
werden immer konkreter.
Die Plazenta ist bei Ihnen
an der Hinterwand.
Hier sieht man einen Teil
und hier drüben den anderen Teil.
Okay.
Das Schwarze ist das Fruchtwasser.
Das sieht auch gut aus.
Super.
Ich würde wahnsinnig gern
natürlich gebären.
Der Gedanke an einen Kaiserschnitt
ist ein Horrorgedanke für mich.
Aber letztlich sollte es das Beste
fürs Kind und für mich sein.
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Frauen
eine positive Einstellung haben
und sich auf die Geburt freuen.
Denn es ist ja ein ersehntes
und langerwartetes Ereignis.
Diese positive Einstellung
spüre ich bei ihr.
Das ist eine
sehr gute Voraussetzung.
Einen Gang runterschalten - damit ist
auch die Gynäkologin einverstanden.
Vier Wochen vor Termin
erhält Larissa ein Arztzeugnis
und hört mit Arbeiten auf.
Okay, gut.
- Vielen Dank.
Bis bald.
- Ja, auf Wiedersehen, Frau Conde.
Auf Wiedersehen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Heute haben wir
noch administrative Dinge erledigt.
Wir waren im Stadthaus in Zürich,
um die Vaterschaftsanerkennung
zu unterschreiben
und um das Sorgerecht zu regeln.
Jetzt hat das Kind
auch offiziell einen Papa.- Genau.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Larissa atmet schwer. *
Wir sind in der
Schwangerschaftswoche 38 angekommen.
Der Bauch wächst.
Es ist Freitagmorgen, 7 Uhr.
Wir sind wieder mal
auf dem Uetliberg.
Zum letzten Mal mit Babybauch.
In Zürich bläst die Bise
und zwei Wochen vor Termin
platzt bei Larissa die Fruchtblase.
Ein Zeichen, dass es losgeht.
Verlieren Sie
immer noch Fruchtwasser?
Ein bisschen, aber nicht viel,
glaube ich.
Soll ich es
noch etwas hochschieben?- Ja.
Das Köpfchen ist schon schön
nach unten ausgerichtet, tipptopp.
Hallo, du, kommst du
früher als geplant? Das ist gut.
Weil die Infektionsgefahr
bei einem Blasensprung gross ist,
wird Larissa regelmässig überwacht.
Der Geburtsprozess sollte
in den nächsten 24 Std. beginnen.
Larissa spürt noch nichts,
Fabian hingegen ahnt etwas.
Wissen Sie, wie der Kopf
bzw. das Gesicht liegt?
Ist es ein Sternengucker?
Nein, das würde ich nicht sagen.
- (Caroline) Ich auch nicht.
Bei dieser Öffnung
kann man noch nicht viel ertasten.
Es ist sicher gut, wenn wir es
mit dem Wehencocktail versuchen.
Wir drücken Ihnen fest die Daumen,
dass es losgeht.- Gut.
Larissa würde lieber nicht einleiten
und hofft, dass der Wehencocktail
aus Rizinusöl und Aprikosensaft
über Nacht wirkt.
Einen Tipp bezüglich Essen
gibt's noch: möglichst scharf.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Am nächsten Morgen
sind sie zurück in der Frauenklinik.
Es geht direkt in den Gebärsaal,
Larissa steht aber
noch etwas neben sich.
(Hebamme) Zimmer Nummer 6.
Waren Sie schon mal hier?- Nein.
Unser schönstes und grösstes Zimmer.
- Wow.
Extra für Sie.
Nicht wahr? Mit Badewanne.
- Das ist wirklich schön.
Es zieht in unregelmässigen
Abständen stark im Bauch.
Ich kann mir die Geburt
noch nicht vorstellen.
Hier steht eine Badewanne.
Das habe ich mir gewünscht, aber
ich kann mir noch nicht vorstellen,
in dieser Badewanne zu sitzen
und das Kind zu gebären.
Mit Akupunktur
will man etwas nachhelfen.
* Larissa atmet tief aus. *
(Hebamme) Die andere Hand auch noch.
- Mmh.
* Seufzen *
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
Eine Stunde später
ist keine Position mehr bequem.
* Stöhnen *
Der Rücken tut so weh.
Ist es bequem?
- Ja, es ist okay.
* Larissa würgt. *
Wie viele Frauen
kämpft auch Larissa gegen Übelkeit.
Jetzt kommt wieder eine.
Die Arbeitsschicht von Caroline Suter
beginnt.
Es ist nun ihre Aufgabe, Larissa
zu unterstützen und zu motivieren.
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo.
Schön, ich freue mich,
dass es losging.
Wie geht's?
- Es geht so.
Eine blöde Frage, was?
Mir ist schlecht,
abwechselnd warm und kalt
und der Rücken tut so weh.
* Sie stöhnt. *
Soll ich es kurz wegnehmen?
- Ich weiss nicht, was tun.
Atmen.
Den Wehenschmerzen zum Trotz -
Larissa und Fabian
möchten ein Erinnerungsfoto.
Du siehst aus
wie das blühende Leben, obwohl ...
Wie lange der Geburtsprozess dauert,
weiss in diesem Moment niemand.
Du brauchst schon
noch etwas Energie.- Mmh.
Was hältst du von einer Bouillon,
die du schluckweise trinken kannst?
Wie wäre das?
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
Mein Rücken ist einfach ...
Larissa klagt immer wieder
über Rückenschmerzen.
* Larissa stöhnt. *
Es hat sich viel getan.
Das tut weh.
Hebamme und Ärztin untersuchen
in regelmässigen Abständen
den Muttermund, der sich öffnen muss.
* Stöhnen *
Wir sind bei 6 cm.
Mmh, und was heisst das?
* Alle lachen. *
Das ist super, mehr als die Hälfte.
Das ist doch gut, oder? Sehr gut.
Das sind die längeren Wehen,
die den Muttermund gut öffnen.
Es ist alles schön weich.
(Flüsternd) Einfach entspannen.
* Piepsen
eines medizinischen Geräts *
Darf ich eine Wehe abwarten,
um zu sehen,
wie es nach unten gedrückt wird?
Der Muttermund
ist jetzt fast ganz geöffnet.
Das Kind liegt nun
weit unten im Geburtskanal.
Aber in welcher Position?
Die Rückenschmerzen sind Anzeichen
für eine besondere Lage,
welche die Hebammen fürchten.
(Caroline)
Richtig kräftig. Nochmals.
* Larissa stöhnt. *
Komm, kräftig, kräftig!
(Natalia) Sehr gut.
- (Caroline) Super. Kannst du noch?
* Larissa schreit. *
Kannst du noch?
Komm, schieb dein Baby raus.
Du schaffst das.
* Larissa schreit. *
Gut, super machst du das.
Und wieder atmen.
(Caroline)
Hinten ist extrem viel Platz.
Weisst du, was es ist, Natalia?
- Ich habe einen Krampf.
Ein Sternengucker.
* Larissa stöhnt schmerzvoll. *
Ein Sternengucker - das Kind hat sich
im letzten Moment noch gedreht
und blickt mit dem Gesicht nach oben.
Das bedeutet mehr Widerstand
im Geburtskanal,
mehr Arbeit für Mutter und Kind
und die beiden Geburtshelferinnen.
Sternengucker brauchen
häufig Hilfe bei der Geburt:
Zange oder Saugglocke.
Caroline Suter und Natalia Conde
müssen abschätzen,
wie es um Larissas
verbleibende Kraft steht.
(Caroline) Du machst einfach
so weiter, tief atmen.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist
noch etwas Extrapower nötig.
Darf ich kurz?
Das, was ich hier vorbereite,
ist Oxytocin.
Das hast du bereits,
aber wir verstärken es etwas,
weil die Wehen
etwas abgenommen haben.
Für dich geht alles
genau gleich weiter.
Wir unterstützen dich einfach etwas.
Du darfst die Beine
richtig nach hinten ziehen.
Du hältst ihren Kopf.
(Natalia) Schieb dorthin,
wo es wehtut.
(Cornelia) Ist die Wehe schon da?
- Ja.
Gut, super.
Schieben, schieben, schieben.
Noch mehr. Komm, komm, komm!
Jawohl.
* Larissa schreit. *
Noch etwas mehr.
Komm, du schaffst es.
Es kommt schon. Und gleich nochmals,
kräftig, kräftig!
Du schaffst es, komm, komm.
Die Ärztin und Hebamme
setzen auf das Wehenhormon
und Larissas starken Willen.
Gut. Nicht mehr pressen.
Es braucht eine letzte Presswehe,
einen Dammschnitt,
und dann - um 20.05 Uhr -
ist es endlich so weit.
Hier kommt sie.
* Das Baby weint. *
Ein Sternengucker.
Schau, was für ein Hörnchen sie hat.
* Larissa und das Baby weinen. *
Ja, hei-ei-ei.
Willkommen, Madame.
Hallo, Schätzchen.
Hallo.
* Das Baby weint. *
Schätzchen.
Nach 12 intensiven Stunden
im Gebärsaal ist Fiona Lina da.
Das gesunde Mädchen hat sich
den Weg auf die Welt erkämpft.
Schätzchen.
Darf ich ihr schon
eine Mütze aufsetzen?
Willkommen auf der Welt, Fiona.
Wir packen dich ein bisschen ein.
Du musst dich auf den Busen legen,
dann kannst du besser atmen.
So.
Es sind Momente fürs Familienalbum.
Schau sie dir an.
- Ich habe sie schon fotografiert.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Die ganzen Schmerzen
sind bereits vergessen.
Jetzt ist sie da.
Unglaublich.
Heute Morgen konnte ich mir
noch nicht vorstellen,
dass sie heute Abend
schon bei uns ist.
So, Spätzchen.
36,6.
Für mich war es auch eine Premiere.
Das ist das erste Sternengucker-Baby
in meiner zweijährigen Tätigkeit
als Hebamme.
Auch für die Hebamme
war es ein erstes Mal.
(Natalia) Ich verabschiede mich.
Gute Erholung und gute Nacht.
Ich komme morgen wieder vorbei.
- Das ist gut.
Vielen Dank.
Gynäkologin Natalia Conde
verabschiedet sich nach der Geburt
und Hebamme Caroline Suter
versorgt Mutter und Kind,
bis sie in der Nacht auf die
Wochenbettabteilung verlegt werden.
Herzliche Gratulation.
- Danke.
Du hast es toll gemacht.
Ich bin stolz auf dich.
Ich hoffe, du auch.- Ja.
Ich glaube, die Lampe können wir
ausschalten, sonst ist es zu warm.
Geht es besser mit dem Kreislauf?
Ja, es geht gut.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Flüsternd)
Jetzt ist Mama wieder da.
(Flüsternd) Hallo, Mausi.
Ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können,
dass mein Fokus
komplett auf unserer Tochter liegt.
Ich machte zwei Wochen lang
praktisch keinen Schritt
nach draussen
und es war mir egal,
dass Sommerwetter herrschte.
Ich war einfach
total zufrieden mit ihr zu Hause
in unserer Baby-Bubble.
Ich habe eine ganz neue Seite
an mir kennengelernt,
die ich nicht erwartet hätte.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
In der Erinnerung
von Larissa und Fabian
wird die Geburt ihrer Tochter
immer einmalig sein.
Und im Stadtspital Zürich
geht Fiona Lina
als Kind Nummer 1'550 des Jahres
in die Geschichtsbücher ein.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022
In der nächsten
Sendung begleiten wir ein Paar
durch eine Risikoschwangerschaft.
(Frau) Jawohl. Wow!
* Sie lacht. *
Bei der Trauerverarbeitung
half mir der Umgang mit den Pferden
am meisten.
So konnte ich mich wieder
auf mich selbst konzentrieren
und ich spürte mich wieder.
Die Pferde
schenken einem ein Körpergefühl
und helfen einem dabei,
auf sein Bauchgefühl zu hören.
Meine Liebe zu Marc fühlt sich an,
als würde ich nach Hause kommen.
Ich hatte einfach den Eindruck,
dass ...
... Eva die Richtige ist,
um eine Familie zu gründen.
(Schmerzerfüllt) Oh, verdammt!
* Sie schluchzt. *
Es ist nicht
so einfach zu verarbeiten -
insbesondere
mit unserer Vorgeschichte -,
wenn das Kind abtransportiert wird
und man es nicht mehr so oft sieht.